the batman was such a big movie that one
of its biggest villains got left on the
cutting room floor no joke matt reeves
the batman took a long time to arrive in
theaters but when audiences finally got
to see it they were met with a truly
intense version of batman who is so
consumed by his quest for vengeance that
he barely has time to be bruce wayne the
film has been a huge success upon
release raking in
128.5 million dollars in its opening
weekend while earning rave reviews from
critics the film pits the caped crusader
against a zodiac killer inspired riddler
who wages a bloody war on the corrupt
members of gotham's elite riddler's
mission also forces bruce to examine his
parents legacy which is called into
question by riddler's cleansing crusade
a wrinkle that adds a nice personal
touch to the sprawling detective
thriller thankfully batman and the
gotham city police department eventually
catch the villain and lock him up in
arkham asylum for his crimes but
remember this is a comic book movie so
we're treated to some obligatory sequel
bait in arkham when the riddler meets a
version of the joker played by american
animals and eternal star barry kyogen we
don't see much of the clown prince of
crime but he does befriend his new
asylum mate reeves previously revealed
that kyogen shot footage with
pattinson's dark knight leading some
fans to decry the fact that these frames
were obviously let on the cutting room
floor
now the infamous deleted scene has
finally been released confirming what we
suspected about barry kyogen's joker
although the theatrical cut of the
batman gives fans a brief glimpse of the
joker it's very careful not to reveal
too much of the villain presumably to
save the full look for a sequel and
thanks to the bright light coming in
from the window behind him his iconic
green hair is barely visible that said
kyogen's gleefully sinister demeanor
sells it perfectly the deleted scene
offers a full look at the joker as it
features the bat visiting him in arkham
asylum as he asks the villain for help
unpacking the riddler's sadistic mind
it's an age-old tactic use a serial
killer to find a serial killer the whole
clip feels like a comic book take on the
silence of the lambs and confirms that
batman and joker have already crossed
paths before
since the movie takes place in bruce's
second year of crime fighting this line
suggests he went up against the clown in
his early vigilante days which is pretty
impressive as a director reeves is
clever he keeps kyogen out of focus for
most of the sequence only revealing the
villain's horrific smile toward the end
of their conversation it's definitely a
unique take on the joker a ghastly
visage with full body scarring this new
version of batman's nemesis is also
missing chunks of his trademark green
hair arkham has clearly not been kind to
him coming up with a fresh take on the
joker was always going to be difficult
for matt reeves because we've had so
many different iterations of this iconic
villain over the years from jack
nicholson's sharp-suited mobster and
heath ledger's unpredictable anarchist
to jared leto's tattooed gangster and
joaquin phoenix's misunderstood comedian
thankfully the director has already
revealed his inspiration for the joker
in this grimy version of gotham he told
ign that the villain has a congenital
disease that left him completely
disfigured and that he's quote very much
out of the conrad white sort of mold
silent film star conrad white's
performance in 1928's the man who laughs
was the original inspiration for the
joker reeves told the outlet he's got
this congenital disease he can never
stop smiling and i was like well maybe
there's something here where it's not
something where he fell in a vat of
chemicals or it's not the nolan thing
where he has these scars and we don't
know where they came from reeves is
clearly a hardcore batman fan and it's
great that he wanted to honor the
origins of the villain in his own way
this is very very personal
the joker's startling look also feels
reminiscent of the nightmarish take of
the character in grant morrison's arkham
asylum a serious house on sirius earth
and since there's an arkham asylum
series planned for hbo max it would be
great if kyogen's joker shows up there
too check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]